[Music]
Trump thumps rival Chumps it's true
Trump is in the lead as Joe's campaign
starts to bleed the Washington Post
slash ABC News poll shows 49 would
definitely or probably vote for Trump in
2024 compared to 42 percent for Joe
Biden that's a difference of seven
percentage points cat
[Laughter]
Harry among Trump's newest supporters
are first lady Jill and Son Hunter
Trump trounces his GOP competition too
and sadly even before any of them got
their nicknames among Republicans 43
percent wanted to get the nomination
compared to 20 percent for Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis and everyone else
is lower than the demand for Bud Light
I'm whistling in the graveyard
meantime Biden's not even popular within
his own party in fact he's so unpopular
his new secret service code is Kamala
Harris
laughs
nearly 60 percent of Dems want another
candidate to win the nomination citing
major concerns with his age and mental
acuity but where were they in 2020 would
you expect it's going to get better
here he was today
as we approached Memorial Day this
weekend and one more day weekend I'm
rushing it
well at least he didn't say Christmas
if he did he would have stopped to buy
an Easter basket
but if these numbers hold Hunter will
need a toilet paper shortage to sell art
but I wonder is this just brutal for
President Biden
this polish is brutal for President
Biden absolutely George
you know bind's in trouble when George
Stephanopoulos has to be honest
what say you Joe
so people don't like me very much big
deal it didn't hurt me last time I went
in the basement I came out I was
President we'll probably do the same
thing again
and you know I've been around I know how
this thing works I grew up on a
two-story farm and we had an old
expression people in glass houses
shouldn't teach the dog new tricks and
that's a true story that's joke
yeah foreign
what is this poll meant to tell
everybody that they got a dump Carmelo
or is or or is Joe got to step aside
what's going on here I have a whole
conspiracy theory and I hope you're
ready for it I think the Democrats know
what they're doing I think they're
trying to bait Republicans into into
into
infighting and eventually Trump being
the nominee and Biden's there to keep
any other legitimate Contender out who
those in charge don't want and they're
going to pull him when the time is right
to put their person there that's
interesting before anyone else can in
other words they're doing everything
they can to keep their primary from
being a democratic election but it won't
be by interesting wow
Loftus what are the guys in the shelter
telling you about the race
on a run
oh
well me and the Gang at the dumpster
when we're talking about politics we
have a theory too like yeah Joe's just a
tool like he's not really running
anything yeah right and then the
Democrats can go oh Joe Biden and his
crazy ideas they're not pulling so well
and they'll replace him with another
useful idiot uh I just love that polls
are still a thing right don't you
remember like in 2016 when everybody's
like oh these polls were way off I'll
never do and it turns out four out of
five of those people were Liars because
here we are again and it's just it's
nice to see reality uh injected back
into America with Trump doing so well
because it's not like he wasn't running
the show for four years and just
crushing on every level I wonder so it's
it's it wasn't like too long ago we
could go wow we can have cheap gas again
world peace peace in the Middle East no
uh nuclear war threat I'll take that
again it would be fun yeah right you
know it is true I mean he he the only
reason why Biden won was Biden hadn't
yet ruined the country right now he's
done it and he and also covid so those
were the things that uh I mean it was it
was it wasn't it was a narrow margin of
Voters but there were two major
variables there and then of course they
changed they actually calm things down
yeah yeah what did he he was a he really
caught my ass
very narrow margin of Voters and if you
know ravensberger had just found them
there's Georgia like I don't know I
don't know why he couldn't just find
them like they're there I promise by the
way find assumes that they're there you
can't find something that doesn't exist
as well that will go away cat um does it
bother you that it still comes down to
two choices and what's even worse it's
the same two choices before you so we
have two choices for eight years
I'm exhausted just thinking about it it
seems so far away and obviously Anything
could happen and all I know for sure is
that whoever loses all of those people
will blame it on me for voting third
party yes
um but I just don't understand like you
point out this was supposed to be the
return to normalcy none of the normal
like and none of it the president is
supposed to be able to like he's not
even that he can just can't really lead
it's that he can't really be expected to
follow somebody away from a Podium I
mean like he he there's 63 or some
percent don't don't think he has the
mental Fitness to be president yeah who
are the rest of the people yes like I I
[Applause]
I want other people are they speaking to
they're like oh that's normal that's how
you that's a normal way to talk who are
those people those are the people that
Joe says he's smarter than right I know
more than anybody he said that and but I
know of course he says Hunter's really
smart all right you're like you're like
our Washington Insider expert and your
hair is not bad either well I got a
haircut yeah I don't like it when you
get a haircut yeah I don't either I want
to run my fingers for you but if I don't
get a haircut it gets kind of yeah out
of control Charlie looking like a goat
are we over analyzing this poll well
yeah well a little bit I mean I mean
polls are kind of meaningless but I
think the fact that that you've got ABC
in Washington Post allowing something
like this yeah they didn't go yeah that
it tells you that it tells you something
right there
um and I think it's probably an accurate
reflection of the electorate um I and it
reminds me why I love American voters
they're like the obnoxious cool guys in
the back of the class who are like not
paying attention ever yeah the media has
spent years and billions of dollars
explaining that that Donald Trump is
unfit for political office and then they
do a poll and they're like yeah Trump
yeah
exactly exactly it's like we just
produce a January 6th miniseries with an
ABC producer and it's like oh yeah yeah
oh yeah that was a bad day but yeah
we're Trump trump yeah we're Trump yeah
the percentage of Americans is who
believe that we could convince Joe Biden
he was at Prince
[Laughter]
seriously I bet we could we could go Hey
Joe how was it oh you were there you had
ice cream
there you go hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else